my mind's going crazy
[Music]
ximena breaks up with mike in a pretty
savage way and clearly he just couldn't
take it
now if you're thinking mike's dramatic
runaway scene is juicy
just wait until you get a glimpse at
what he's going to say to ximena next
week
i pay the rent in this house so i'm not
leaving
and that's not even all of it plus will
you marry me
geno's proposal to jasmine
and jasmine detailing the love she has
for him i love him from
ball head to toe just the way he is
weird
creepy sometimes but gives us another 90
day we love to see it moment i was just
very happy that you gave me a chance
if you laughed while gina was crying
you are wrong for that it's beautiful my
gosh let's talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia before
we get started i just want to say i
appreciate y'all so much and all the
love you show in the comments it means
more than you know
hugs also before we hop into mike taking
off i had a good chat with kim and we
went there what do you regret what you
would have done differently
oh that whole that whole scene with me
in the pink nightgown i was mortified i
embarrassed myself i embarrassed usman i
embarrassed my son you know you'll be
able to see the full interview this week
on et's youtube channel or etonline.com
alright let's get into mike and ximena
quick refresh after mike tried to end
things with ximena she told him she
wanted to work it out
they ended up getting intimate that
night
but afterwards she told him she didn't
want to sleep in the same bed with him
until they're married it must not have
been very good inappropriate anyway that
brings us to this episode ximena is
acting colder than ever toward mike i'm
really just tired of walking on
eggshells reading between the lines
thinking about what's going on in
jimena's head her excuse for her change
in behavior is that she's learned he's
quote weird and quote a filthy person
but her mom and her sister are urging
her to treat him better because he's a
great opportunity for her and her kids i
don't know how i feel about that i mean
ximena's mom says that mike is the only
person who has shown her daughter
unconditional love he doesn't care that
she has children and he treats her
family as if they are his own
to sum it up she basically says ximena
is not being smart
ximena's mom even goes as far as asking
mike to be patient with ximena because
she has never had a serious relationship
i really didn't know that she uh didn't
have a serious relationship up until me
which i know she was coming from a good
place by saying that but she also was
setting mike up for failure because that
conversation got his hopes up
and ximena is about to tear it all down
come
after mike's conversation with ximena's
mom he decides to take ximena to the
pool hall
and her rudeness at this point is next
level that is
[Music]
he does look the same but
damn
so i talked to your mom last night
mike brings up the fact that ximena's
mom told him she hasn't had a serious
relationship before
but according to her
that's not true
okay
but
why do you want to get married then
ximena goes on to say for her it's
difficult to be with one person because
she's really young and all she wants to
do is have fun and enjoy herself
by the way i forget she's 24.
ximena adds that maybe in the future
she'll sacrifice her freedom but mike
does things that are annoying and she
doesn't know if he is the man for her
which we are not going to argue with you
about that sweetheart from the looks of
it i don't think he is either
no messi
back the [ __ ] off wow ximena did say
mike is always following her
after they play pool for a bit they sit
down to chat
and little does mike know he's about to
get dumped
isn't it nice when we have fun together
just us
[Music]
but did he ask you that
[Music]
mike then said what he should have said
to ximena a long time ago
i just can't stop thinking that your
feelings changed when i stopped saying
yes to buying everything
why is she acting like she can't read
the translator now
[Music]
[Music]
no she didn't
she said it can't be the money because
you're still giving it to me and i still
don't like you
by the way here's how much mike said
he's paid for her rent so far when i
spoke to him last month i would say
rent is like five red and food is like
500 a month for
um
so it's just about a year and a half now
so
that's like nine grand right there
ximena then tells mike she was offended
by what he said and if he thought she
was just using him for money
he doesn't know the real her amigos
cosas
so you just want to be friends that's it
after this whole year and a half
[Music]
[Music]
after ximena breaks up with mike he
tells her he wants to take everything he
paid for back with him to new york
which was hard to take seriously because
it's basically her whole house and that
would be expensive
is
i guess she's ready to go back to work
meanwhile mike mentally can't take this
anymore
[Applause]
you know what
i'm done
[Music]
i don't know what i did wrong everything
she said on the first trip i tried to
fix myself
[Music]
my mind's going crazy
[Music]
mike is doing all this running around in
this bright yellow shirt he needs to
make sure he is aware of his
surroundings
i'm sure the cameraman was annoyed i'm
not sure where he ended up running too
but i guess we'll find out next week
overall this entire situation is proof
when you get into a relationship for the
wrong reasons
you don't just end up hurting the other
person you'll eventually end up hurting
yourself because the more they get
attached the harder it is for you to get
out of it plus
everything you've done to me
[Music]
already done to you
aka karma is a ximena's still young
hopefully she learns from this and when
it comes to mike i hope he's learned
changing yourself so someone will love
you
never works
never everything she said on the first
trip i tried to fix myself
all right here's the moment i've been
waiting to show you this is a glimpse of
what's going to go down next week
this only reinforces the fact that you
were using me for money because right
now you're cold and calculated
i pay the rent in this house so i'm not
leaving
she's a mean
evil
cold
[ __ ]
whoa
it was the final
we had the
that did it for me
all right let's end things on a lighter
note and quickly touch on geno and
jasmine at the top of the episode these
two are fresh off a big argument that
was sparked after jasmine got a message
from someone threatening to post the
nude photos gino sent his ex-girlfriend
of her online
and jasmine was upset because gino told
her not to worry about it he didn't
understand that it's a big deal for me
another issue arises when jasmine goes
through gino's email and finds out he
went on a trip with his ex-girlfriend in
2016
which he didn't tell her about
now the trip happened before they even
knew each other existed so gino
exploded i think i remember everything i
did six years ago stop lagging
although jasmine is still upset about
everything she decides that she's not
ready to give up on their love so she
goes and apologizes to gino for her
behavior in the relationship jasmine is
continuously
punishing me over and over for some
mistakes i made
i'm sorry if my actions my words
everything like from me heard you
apology accepted and gino apologizes for
his actions as well
when i forgive your stupidity for the
messages and all that
because i was stupid
yes
i know sorry about that
i was just very happy that she gave me a
chance
[Music]
i'm glad you gave me a chance oh geno
they both agreed to wipe the slate clean
and i don't know what it is about these
two
but the love they have for each other
is real
he
has become my best friend like
my support system
and
i love him from
ball head to toe just the way he is
weird
creepy sometimes but
i also know the sweet intelligent
version of you know i know we're toxic
sometimes but we are in love
all right let's get into the proposal
gino takes jasmine to this beautiful
mountain size
and pulls out the ring
and all i could think was gino
turn the box around
i don't know if this umbrella is not
helping
at all
jasmine
ever ever since i met you
on march 8th
you've had such a
amazing connection together
ever since that day
[Music]
you make me feel very loved
i've never felt so loved before like
you love me
[Music]
and
make me the happiest man
so
jasmine
will you marry me
and she said
of course yes
[Music]
now i think we all know that this
relationship has its issues but their
love has been able to supersede it all
and that's why once again i'm giving
geno and jasmine the 90 day we love to
see it moment this week
oh wait y'all have to see jasmine's
reaction to the ring take a look
it's a beautiful ring
i love it i like it
um but maybe because i know my fingers
they are so skinny
this is kind of big
and i don't know if it is a diamond or
not
[Music]
to be honest i am not an expert in
diamonds
um
i just did it based off uh
comparing it to other rings he had in
the store and i thought it was
it looked the best to me
it's it's
it's screams you know this ring that's
why i love it it screams you know here's
a better shot of the ring
it's cute
all right next week geno has to have a
tough conversation with jasmine so
hopefully the piece they are enjoying
right now will last through it
i proposed to her and she said yes
i'm nervous about bringing up the issue
of a prenup because i just don't want to
like piss her off
and end our relationship on the spot
[Music]
we'll see all right 90 day fans fam make
sure you stick with e.t because we are
covering it all i will see you next time
[Music]